durant goes to retrieve
shot clock down to four
he'll pull from deep and put it in
average 32-footer
especially he still is able to score
going away from him
and drill a 34-footer for three spurs by
one
[Music]
more again on the attack against pirtle
air time
timeout san antonio
[Applause]
kelden johnson was back
crowd murmuring in anticipation
morant spins and figures it in
sensational john moran and the grizzlies
have the lead
he was able to get the stop he said you
know used to be me and dylan playing
defense now we got a lot of guys that
can defend the mcgregor
after a made free throw marant
quick silver and sneakers
look how quickly off of the made free
throw kyle anderson gets it out of
bounds and throws it to morant at the
half court line
grizzlies have gone from
six down to seven up
adams cuts and finishes marine with a
laser
[Applause]
bullet pass that steven adams does a
great job
this by walker rebound by adams his
sixth
miranda blows by primo attacks
wow
john marant over yaakov purdle
must see tv
morant for three good again
unbelievable stuff from john moran 25
both teams with a foul to give six
seconds a different shot clock to game
clock
marant around pearl again all the way
through to the riven
murray one of two
the bench still standing
going long mourinho
insanity
look at this he tells me throw it along
get my feet underneath me in the air
behind the basket
[Applause]
i don't know which one is better i mean
look the dunk of course the duck is the
one that's gonna get you out of the seat
but this is amazing to be able to catch
the ball
point four as you are floating away from
behind the basket still knocks it down
more triple doubles than any spur in
franchise history for his career morant
again threw the lane into the class
because of the grizzlies turnovers and
the fact that san antonio sitting on one
turnover for the game morant yes
shares that record with 18.
anderson moran against trey jones he
spins he flips it up
john miranda i just shake my head we're
seeing things that
[Music]
tilly for three
rebound morant
reverses it up and in
41 for marantz
great job that is that you have to close
out straight to his body marantz
straight line drive figure rolls it up
and in
timeout san antonio
44 for morant for the second time
against san antonio in two seasons
uh-oh crosses over against
[Applause]
yes
look at this here that's the 50.